cining was a minor Communist Party
official when he first visited San
Francisco in 1985 he now returns as
Chinese president and will meet us
leader Joe Biden in their first
face-to-face encounter in a year taking
place on the sidelines of the Apex
Summit it's hoped this meeting will
reduce Rising tensions between the two
world powers it comes as both China and
the US face economic challenges both
sides have a tremendous amount at stake
and it is better for them to have
economic cooperation even if it's
limited than it is for them to uh you
know on both sides not only have
uncertainties within their economies but
creating uncertainties in the global
economy Washington says the two
countries are interdependent but that
hasn't stopped it from moving to drisk
when it comes to trade with China it's
called on us allies to do the same the
Biden Administration has also blocked
beijing's access to crucial
semiconductor chips and equipment and
sanctioned Chinese technology firms for
national security reasons in the Asia
Pacific the US opposes China's
militarization of the South China Sea
disputed territory claimed by Beijing as
well as pressure it puts on Taiwan a
self-governed island allied with
Washington on the global stage China has
been wanting to play a bigger role
strengthening ties with Russia despite
condemnation from the West for its
invasion of Ukraine and calling for an
immediate ceasefire in the Gaza Strip
both positions osed by the us while the
C Biden meeting is a key step towards
improving us China relations analysts
say that geopolitical rivalry is here to
stay so what can be achieved both sides
are keeping expectations low but there
are opportunities for
cooperation a new climate change working
group has been announced and Washington
says it's Keen to reopen lines of
military communication lines cut off by
Beijing last August when former US House
speaker Nancy Pelosi visited Taiwan the
two leaders are also expected to discuss
stemming the tide of fenel to the US and
the regulation of artificial
intelligence in drone Weaponry Katrina U
alaz
ping make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer